[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 51th episode of chess trap
series
in today's lecture we are going to look
at
one of the modern marcosi trap in the
sicilian defense
from the black perspective now anybody
who plays the accelerated dragon
knows very well how critical
marcosi bind is as the critical position
arises after the following opening motor
e4 c5 knight to f3
knight to c6 d4 c captures d4
knight captures d4 and now the trademark
accelerated dragon move g6
now since there is no pressure on e4
everybody knows that one of the best
reply is
c4 creating this bind
on d5 here
i am going to recommend a crafty motor
so first you should start with knight
web 6
attacking on e4 and after knight to c3
defending now we go bishop to g7
well why we are doing this
and the answer is very simple we are
allowing y
to make a mistake
there are two ways white can reach to
marcosi bind from here onwards
but unfortunately one of them
leads to disaster
our main trap occurs when white plays
the move bishop to e2
however in case if you are wondering
what to do against the move bishop to e3
then my recommendation is you should
play
knight to g4 taking the advantage of
attacking that bishop and after the
following continuation
queen captures g4 knight captures d4
looking at juicy c2 square so queen to
d1 is forced
and after that one option is you can
continue with
e5 but i like the straightforward one
knight to e6 and as you can see
i have highlighted by the arrows very
effective plan of campaign by black
and as per the database black score is
very reasonable from this position
so probably that is the reason why here
why choose the another big option namely
bishop to e2 first stopping knight to g4
idea
and in fact as per the online database
there are more than 100 games as well as
roughly 5000 leeches games
goes into this direction where i'm
afraid
white has straight away fallen into
black trappy territory
can you see a dazzling shot here
yup black has this amazing winning shot
knight captures e4 bam
so at this point now black is a clear
pawn up
and white cooperate very well let's say
if you take over knight then after
knight captures d4
castle and black castle indeed
with this extra pawn and some careful
play
black can easily score the full point
so nope that's not the way to play
and accordingly here the most critical
response is
knight captures c6 counter-attacking the
black queen
and then intending to take on e4
now if you run this position in any
chess engine the engine suggests that
you should play knight capture c3 and
even though the resulting position is
quite good for the black i think the
emerging end game
is not so clear cut as per the human
perspective
so instead of that i am going to
recommend this straightforward approach
bishop capture c3 okay
white response is force he has to take
this bishop
and after that yup you guessed it
d capture c6
now if you carefully look at this
position not only black is a clear pawn
up
but white has some shattered pawn
structure on the queen side
so if white avoid the queen trade let's
say queen to c2
then after bishop to f5 black get
a very good middle game with
healthy structure and upon advantage
so accordingly the only reply which
keeps white
in the game is queen to d4
attacking the two pieces
okay now black response is forced
he has to capture this queen and after
pawn captures d4
the dust is clear and one can easily see
that
black emerged with a clear pawn
advantage
and although white has a bishop pair i
think with the accurate play
this is great position for the black
camp
on you might think the trap is alright
well it's not the case because
still black can go for more with
bishop to e6 and
believe it or not but it completely
stopped
white to castle on the king's side
that is the most popular choice so let's
see
what is wrong after this natural move
now by force black is winning
the second pawn yup you heard it right
and the tricky sequence start with
knight to d6 attacking on c4
so white response is force he has to
play c5
and there comes knight to f5
pressurizing the d4 pawn
here it doesn't matter however white
defend on d4 with the bishop let's say
bishop to b2 is the most popular choice
after that we can simply castle
and as you can see very simple plan for
the black camp is
to double the rook on the d-file and
grab
the d-pawn
well you might think that's not possible
because
white can also double on d file but the
big problem is
in that process the a2 pawn hangs
let me demonstrate here first thing
first
if bishop to d3 this is a great mistake
here by white
as once again black has this tactical
resource
boom
so that after bishop captures d4 and the
move rook to d8
black get his piece back with the
interest
so that's not a good choice so the only
good move here
is rook to d1 but after that
rook to d8 white can see what is coming
up
so first he need to protect the a pawn
and it doesn't matter
whether the a3 or a4 let's say in one
game
a4 happened black indeed
double up the rook and white followed
the suit
with rook to d2 but what he missed is
after rook to d8 rook to d1
the winning shot for the black
yup bishop to b3 and
sadly white rook has to
go out of the d-file and after that
yup another pawn goes down the hill
with knight captures d4 and i'm sure
after this 19th move long trap
black should mop up the game very
quickly
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trap in the mark cozy bind
remember if you open and continue with
this inaccurate move
bishop to e2 then don't forget to punish
him
with knight captures e4 and as
i have shown in this video all the
complication
leads to in the favor of the black
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care